teenager young entrepreneurs it's
important for you to know that you have
an edge
over 30 40 and 50 year olds and here's
what it is i don't think
most know about it but you ought to know
about it and here's what it is look
when i was 18 years old 19 years old in
the army
we would party friday night until three
four o'clock in the morning after a full
day after i woke up at four o'clock
to go to formation and we would stay up
till three four o'clock in the
night in the morning we'd wake up the
next day come back go hit the gym
party again the following night saturday
till three four o'clock in the morning
come back go hit the gym and then boom
sunday night i would go party at a a
club in nashville that was a country
music club and i would come home at two
o'clock
formations at four five o'clock going on
two three hours and we're working
running
and you know five miles four miles and
then working on hummers and trucks and
then coming back
hitting the weights and then going to
sleep at night and i did this for years
and years and years so when i got out of
the army i understood as a 20
year old i had an edge because i knew
i had stamina that was my edge over some
30 40 50
or 50 year olds that maybe didn't have
that kind of a stamina to compete so you
have that stamina
going for yourself you you the other
edge that you have going for yourself is
the fact that the older you get
30 year olds who have a degree fantasy
degree or 40 year olds and 50 year olds
who maybe
like director or vice president or
whatever they may be they have a hard
time saying i don't know
it's like hey you ever heard of john doe
oh yeah i've heard of them before
you've never heard of them before but 30
40 50 year olds say what oh i've heard
of them before
because they have hard times saying i
don't know but you're a teenager
entrepreneur you're a teenager
you're a young entrepreneur you have the
power of saying i don't know
teach me i don't know teach me i don't
know
teach me which what that does is to
everybody that wants to teach you their
secret sauce that they typically
wouldn't teach to everybody else
the idea of saying i don't know teach me
gets a person from this
to guards down because you're no longer
a threat so they're willing to really
teach you
the the deeper element of winning in
business or whatever maybe
versus the 30 40 year olds like i know
too much so they will never say i don't
know which means they're not going to
ask the questions
which means they're not going to be as
curious because they have a degree or
they read 50 books
or they read the right articles or
whatever they have they can't say i
don't know you as a teenage entrepreneur
and a young entrepreneur you have the
stamina going for yourself
you have the ability to say i don't know
the opposition's willing to have their
guards come down that they're willing to
share the real deep insight with you on
what it takes to win in any kind of an
industry
and then the other one that you have
going for yourself at a young age is the
final one
look when you're 35 and you're married
one day you wake up with a woman next
your man next you call husband and wife
and you got two three kids that are
screaming saying mommy
daddy waking you up in the middle of the
night
and most parents from that moment on
rather than
using the kids as a motivation to go out
there and win use the kids as an excuse
to say well
you don't understand i got no sleep last
night
it was so crazy and oh my gosh
i wish this this this all these things
they're gonna use right to say
i got no sleep last night which is right
they didn't get any sleep last night
they're right they didn't get any sleep
last night
but most people it takes to their mid
30s and 40s
to realize when you have a baby you
learn
you could have all this time gone with
four to six hours of sleep for many many
years
but you didn't know you could because
you partied hardcore and slept your
eight to ten hours and you wasted
your twenties you wasted your teens
because you party cons you wasted it
partying is
overrated this is coming from a guy that
did plenty of it
it's overrated it this i figured this
part out at 24 years old 25 years old
and it gave me an edge if you think
about it because i had a five year edge
i have a sick
many of my peers party took their
mid-30s i stopped at 23 24 25.
you're watching this you're 15 years old
16 years old 17 18 19 20 21 22 whatever
age you may be i'm not telling you to
live a boring life i'm not telling you
that i'm not telling you go be
square and boring i'm not telling you to
go do that
all i'm saying is be very aware
that you have so much energy that you
don't even know you have
you have to be 50 to know the energy you
have you have to be 60 to know the
energy up
you have it that energy is priceless you
can't even put a value on it it's not
like it's worth a million dollars or 10
million
or billion dollars it's priceless any 60
year old would do
anything to exchange their energy with
yours
of what you had at 18 19 20 or so so if
you use that
use the power of i don't know you use
the power of bringing people's guards
down where they're willing to
share with you what worked for them and
you have the power
to sit out there and work where you
don't have to worry about the kids
liability responsibility pressures all
this other stuff
to learn at 35 years old that you have a
different gear that you can tap into
that the only time people learn that
they can tap into is when they have a
kid and they realize there are nuts you
can only get two hours
and you're still gonna have to go to
work you're still gonna go to have to
there's been nights i want to sleep
i'm like wow i had three of them i got
another one on the way not about to go
through the face again in the next few
months right
and like oh my gosh and you go to work
and no one knows you're going on two and
a half hours of sleep because every
hour and a half or two hours you woke up
because the kid was sick or whatever
happened drooling
all this that's the stuff where you say
oh my gosh i'm capable of doing so much
more so
teenage and younger entrepreneurs if you
watch this
i can give you 20 more things that you
have an edge over
you have to know this yourself so for
the right person watching this if a
parent
share this video with somebody else
that's that age and they're sitting
there saying oh my gosh i never thought
about it this way before
if you do it the right way your future
looks bright
and by the time you're 25 years old 30
years old if you find the right person
in your early 20s to work with that you
shadow
and you start getting caught up in this
whole thing about passion you get caught
up into the right person to shadow
by 35 years old you have all the money
you can go buy a night club a restaurant
and call it after your name if you
wanted to
because you did it the right way you
maximize
the error of being a teenager and a
young entrepreneur how much
value there is behind that if you watch
this video
and you want to know a little bit more
about a message like this i did a video
years ago
titled the most biggest mistakes i made
my first year as an entrepreneur
you ought to know this if you've never
seen this video it's an old video
go watch this video i share with you the
biggest mistakes i made
as a young entrepreneur having said
let's have a great week everybody
take care bye